like many government workers across
Bangladesh mamad Mina is trying to
survive by cutting
costs the latest pay increase offer will
hardly help us what we are getting now
with overtime can barely meet our demand
for rent and food Essentials let alone
other expenses that I have like sending
money home to my in-laws or for my
children's
education workers and union leaders say
they face intimidation and harassment
when they protest and their
demonstrations are often forcefully
suppressed by
police we are unable to express our
sorrows and rightful demand as the
police violently crack down on us by
using bullets and tear gas police say
some of the worst violence has taken
place in industrial
areas we don't want anyone to get hurt
or lose their lives we are doing our
duty with the utmost caution and
diligence to maintain order we are
extremely sorry for any lives lost in
recent
protests about 4,000 clothing factories
account for 85% of Bangladesh's $55
billion annual exports to supply many of
the world's top brands clothing Factory
owners say they're under pressure
because International brands are
offering lower prices than before and
low wages have helped Bangladesh remain
competitive in the global market the
government has fixed the new minimum
monthly wage for garment Factory workers
at around
$115 but workers are demanding nearly
double that research shows that
Bangladeshi garment workers got the
lowest monthly wages in the world
compared to other garment producing
countries you have to realize if the
workers do not have proper nutrition and
diet there is going to be lower
productivity and efficiency there is an
increasing upward trend for food prices
rent and other essential Goods first
workers are demanding better pay
now garment manufacturers have urg their
employees to return to work with Rising
inflation and soaring foot prices it's
not just the Garment workers who are out
protesting others with fixed incomes
have also taken to the streets in recent
months a major challenge for the
government ahead of general election due
in January T chadre Al jazer ashulia
Industrial
Area make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer